you know there's a lot of talk about
action choreography and fight
choreography and these series
i want to talk to you about your dance
choreography
baron zemo dancing it out in madrid poor
like is that the way daniel gets down is
that you in real life
this is zemo style um
i'm i'm also very passionate uh dancer
on the floor
um if necessary i can be contained and
and subtle and sophisticated but i um
i i like to go i like going for it
um my friends uh very often tell me how
embarrassing it is when the spanish side
kicks in
and i i do some matador moves and you
know flamenco style
but um in this what we see in madrid
this is
this is zemo um and it wasn't on the
page it was improvised and i thought
it's it's so much fun
because uh you know this guy has been
sitting uh sitting in and
and rotting in a in a german prison cell
so it's time to let off some steam and
also
i like the i like the way sam and bucky
reacting to it uh you know being
truly uh annoyed but um
i thought for zemo is you know his
tactic is the more
noticeable you are in that moment uh the
less suspicion you arouse
um but i think sam and bucky clearly see
that different
i love that uh that idea of you just
going for it in real life on the dance
floor and you're really going for it
with this character too what's
interesting about
zemo is that we see this in this one
episode all these different shades to
the character that we didn't even see in
a full movie before
what was your reaction to the approach
that um the creators wanted to take
with zemo this time around it is
wonderful
when that happens um well first of all
to get the call that you
you're allowed to revisit something but
then also to be allowed
to um to do something else with it
uh to not repeat yourself and continue
you know on the on the same path
which i wouldn't have minded because i i
loved uh playing
zemo in the um in civil war
but uh to have the privilege of showing
so much more
and and and so many different sides to
that character was uh thrilling you know
um because first of all if you think of
the comic books
it was great to finally wear the mask so
to start with you know and i thought
like that that's what i missed in in
in civil war at least for once i want to
wear that mask
but then also that that coat that iconic
uh aristocratic look which made you
understand that he's a baron you know
so to be able to show that whole
background
and then in your performance to play
with that slightly posh and suave and
arrogant
you know uh attitude to add some sense
of humor
uh to it i'm always a fan of that you
know
um to lighten things up no matter how
serious they are
um and um so that was
that was wonderful the only the only
question and then
i was very nervous uh um about the
people's reaction because
um i mean these you know the
mcu lives from its fans that millions of
billions of
truly and very dedicated fans and i i
just thought will they
accept and embrace that you know because
it can also happen
in in in in other films and shows that
you establish something
and if you surprise people with
something very different they might you
know be disappointed and think like why
is he so
why does he dance like that
so um if people
like it and respond to it uh well uh it
makes me very happy
yeah well listen it's working so far and
i can't wait to see more
of how zimmer develops thank you so much
for this time great chatting with you
thank you
you